The increasing incidence of hospital-
acquired staphylococcal infection is
prompting nurses and other medical
personnel to re-evaluate procedures
employed in patient care. Since most disease producing organisms
are destroyed when proper septic
procedures are used, hand-washing is
considered the most practical and
consistent defense against the spread of infection.
The following scenes demonstrate an accepted method requiring 60 to 90 seconds to perform.
Hand-washing should include the forearms up to the area pointed out by the nurse.
Using either cake or liquid soap, first lather the hands thoroughly,
then rub the dorsal and palmar surfaces applying approximately ten friction movements.
Next, interlace the fingers and cleanse the interdigital spaces, again with ten friction movements.
Now soak the forearms and rub each for
10 to 15 seconds.
Always rinse carefully, allowing the
water to flow from forearms toward the fingertips.
After repeating the hand-washing
procedure, clean the fingernails.
A toothbrush may be used for this purpose.
Dry the hands and forearms thoroughly
with a paper towel.
Then with a dry portion of the towel, turn off the water faucet.
To prevent skin irritation, complete the handwashing with an application of a suitable lotion or cream.